before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsors of this video
Crosse Chronicle it's a unique collector
mobile RPG where yokai's and human team
up with the yokai's powers to fight
enemies one of the things which I liked
about this game is that you experience
varying dialogue options that change
based on your decisions you can take
advantage of the strategic fusion system
which allows your human hunters to
borrow powers from youkai so you need to
customize your team of yokai and hunters
carefully deciding which one suit your
playstyle click the link in the
description to download cross Chronicle
for free Hunter hunter is how you do
shown in anime right the 2011 reboot of
the 1999 original based on Yoshihiro
Togashi she's manga is a hundred and
forty eight episodes log as we've seen
with long-running series they suffer
from an inevitable drop in quality over
time plot lines tend to get an
imaginative characters get tired and
stop evolving and even the animation
suffers too it's a disease that gets to
the best of them thankfully hunter
hunter doesn't go through that the
retelling of the story of gone freaks a
young boy whose dream of being a
professional hunter takes him on a path
of adventure and danger starts pretty
slow as the naive and infectious the
enthusiastic gone makes new friends and
enemies along the way the show gets
better and better with each episode in
each arc
additionally light-hearted it gets
progressively darker until the line
between the good and bad guys are so
blurred you just don't know what to
think
the storytelling is tight every
characters fleshed out and memorable and
the change in tone never seems contrived
the action sequences the holy grail of
shown in shows never let you down
efficiently crafted and never dull
Hunter hunter also has moments of pure
brilliance that shock and awe it's only
appropriate that we dedicate today's
video to the top 10 moments from the
show
[Applause]
we start off with kilowatt one-shot kill
this is one of those moments where the
darkness of Hunter hunter smacks you in
the face without warning it comes as
early as episode 11 in the hunter exam
arc gone killer kora pika and lay Oreo
for friends and hunters to be must
defeat a team of notorious prisoners to
make it through to the next round
kilowatt zodiacs matched against Jonas
the dissector a mass murderer known for
dismembering his victims with his bare
hands it seems to be an unequal match
but not how we think in a flash killer
plucks Jonases heart out of his chest
with his bare hands leaving his
teammates terrified except for gone who
explains to them calmly the killer is
from a family of elite assassins it's
hard to believe the easygoing kid we
first saw riding a skateboard is a
cold-blooded murderer for hire whose
kill switch may come on at any time
[Music]
nay Oreo who looks much older than his
teen years is a big brother figure two
gone and the rest of his friends he
takes this role very seriously if this
becomes clear in episode 140 when he
lectures Jing for being an absent father
- gone Jing abandoned gone as a baby to
pursue a career as a hunter and while
gone bears him no ill will and even
aspires to be like him his friends
aren't too thrilled with Jiang's
parental neglect Li Oreo is enraged when
Jing refuses to commit to visiting gone
who's barely held on to his life and
sanity after a particularly bruising
battle and is in hospital he channels
his anger into one immensely satisfying
empowered punch - Jing smugface gotta
say you deserve that Jing
[Music]
lightning speed in godlike reflexes meet
in this next moment when kilowatt shows
why he may be the coolest customer in
the hunter universe up against the beast
like you'd be one of three royal guards
in the service of the Chimera and King
Mero M Kilowog goes into God's speed
mode and ability that as its name
suggests allows him to move and react
above and beyond the limits of his body
for a short period of time transformed
into a Silver Streak of raw power he
hits you P with a barrage of nen towered
electric attacks to which the much
stronger and bigger Chimaera ant has
absolutely no answer it's one of the
coolest David and Goliath clashes in the
series it also serves as a reminder of
kilowatts dark past because this ability
and power of born of the family imparted
torture training and electric shocks
that formed the young assassins
childhood
up next we have kites death of the many
friends and villains gone meets on his
journey none perhaps has the impact that
kite does on the young hunter a chance
to find his father leads gone to kite
Jing's former students instead the two
form a strong bond despite not spending
much time together in the Chimera ant
arc kite gon and killua find themselves
up against Pete oh another one of Mary
M's Royal Guards heavily disadvantaged
against the Chimera ant kite sacrifices
himself to save the two boys the sight
of Pete Oh nestling kites lifeless head
in her lap is one of the most disturbing
moments in Hunter hunter again coming
with absolutely no warning more
profoundly kites death is the catalyst
for a sea change in God's character at a
later stage for one of the most iconic
moments in anime history suffice to say
kites death is a moment of awakening
foregone in more ways than one
tourists catenaccio Akasha Don okay tone
inaudible a percentage to receive
whatever amana like the sludge cutter
and if kilowatts Godspeed is or
inspiring but not altogether surprising
goo Rebecca's Emperor time is just as
amazing and quite unexpected the lone
survivor of the court our clan bears a
deep grudge against the Phantom troop a
gang of thieves who massacred his people
for their scarlet eyes this thirst for
revenge shapes much of goo Rebecca's
character and his nan ability which
takes the form of five chains on his
right hand that have been specially
conjured to bring down the spiders as
the troop members are called in the
battle against rogue in goo Rebecca
reveals a frightening power that
elevates the thinking hunter to a
terrific combatant which many of us may
not have expected Emperor time takes
over when qu Rebecca's eyes turned
scarlet transforming the natural
conjurer into a specialist with a
hundred percent control over all six and
then categories it's a power that
doesn't quite fit the young man with a
gentle voice while on the one hand qu
Rebecca uses Emperor timer to great risk
to his own life on the other hand the
office despair will give his life if he
answers his questions with honesty this
duality is a masterful summary of Hunter
Hunter's innate ability to turn out
multi-layered characters kicking off the
top five we have the moment gone and the
hunters infiltrate the palace in the
kingdom of East Goro for their final
assault on my ruin entering a portal
previously placed by expert infiltrator
and member of the hunter Association
naav gone and gang immediately run into
you be sitting on the staircase leading
to the King's Chamber to get to marrow
him they must get past this powerful
enemy first meanwhile a second
simultaneous castle invasion is under
way this time from the sky hunter
Association chairman Isaac Madero and
kilowog's grandfather xennos Olvia crash
land on Peto and poof the third royal
guard in a meteor shower of dragon aura
as the animation switches to slow motion
to capture the emotion on each face
during the twin break-ins the stage is
set for the show's most memorable fights
and unexpected outcomes some of which
will come up later on in this video at
this point we can only wait to see how
my ruin his powers not yet revealed will
meet the
Hunter's challenge oh yeah
I mean cool
[Music]
[Applause]
the next moments pure poetry
a beautiful dirge to a fallen comrade as
part of his plan to raid the Mafia
communities auction phantom troop leader
crawler Lucifer kidnaps the nostril a
family's daughter and gets her to write
him a fortune with her nen abilities the
fortune hits home as it speaks of Vogons
death in memory of his dead partner who
loved a good fight
chrono orders the rest of the spiders to
head for the auction venue and go wild
even as he engages the mafia hitmen sent
after him it's a brilliant spectacle of
mayhem action and emotion all set to the
haunting music of Mozart lacrimosa and
the fortune tellers words this moment
cements Kronos position as one of the
series most charismatic villains it
gives the troupe a depth view antagonist
groups and Shonen anime get the spiders
come across as a close-knit family and
not a group of unfeeling thieves they
might as a rule welcome anyone who kills
a member into their fold and it might
not be averse to slaughtering a roomful
of people but they're more than their
villainy and this Requiem beautifully
captures this complexity for a moment of
beauty - one of great sadness at the
beginning it's hard to think of Miriam
as anything but two murderous mutant
whose first action is to kill his mother
but a single chance encounter with the
blind and clumsy Kaimuki turns his
character completely on its head what
starts off as a game to kill time takes
Miriam on a life-altering journey that
confounds him as much as it does us it's
fascinating to see this cruel and
violent King grow her heart and to be
brought to his knees not by a skilled
hunter but a defenseless human girl at
the risk of giving away the story of
Mara we're close to death and almost
blind after an epic final battle seeks
out Kaimuki who's also fatally wounded
the chapter on their unlikely friendship
closes with a final game of gungi that's
sure to bring tears to the most hardened
hearts making an antagonist like Miriam
capable of such raw emotion and making
it believable is perhaps one of Hunter
Hunter's biggest achievements
Masai Mara Hema racemosa fuga Ikki
mascara Eric no middlin my sour nanu
Walker Jane you
Nina so courses are nine Chico the
battle between the Darrell and the ant
King is a masterclass of action and
analysis experience and natural talent
with a good bit of mutual admiration
thrown in after losing an arm and a leg
maderos on the verge of death but it
just so happens that the wily old hunter
holds the winning card against his
seemingly invincible opponent Madera
unleashes a final attack a suicide bomb
that triggers only when his heart stops
before this ultimate sacrifice he shows
his enemy one last act of kindness
fulfilling his wish of knowing the name
left to him by his dying mother a
victorious but defeated Mara where
admits the old hunter had him a
checkmate all along and that arrow gets
a send-off that few mentors in Shonen
anime managed to achieve
[Music]
send a Tata
what Emily
[Music]
if you haven't already noticed the hero
of this series gone is barely featured
on this list but that all changes right
now the most memorable moment in Hunter
hunter belongs to the boy whose story
this is after all it also ties up with
another moment earlier on the list
kites death in the inevitable fight to
the death between God and pizza that we
knew was coming
God's forced to face the truth of kites
death but instead of acceptance and
sorrow he's overcome by grief and hate
and snaps setting off undoubtedly the
most terrifying transformation in anime
history sacrificing his life energy and
all of his nen abilities gone turns into
an older stronger and altogether
unrecognizable version of himself gone
is the light from his eyes only a blind
desire for revenge exists gone too is
Pizza as earlier confidence and only
fear remains besides have being
completely switched what ensues is a
brutal one-sided takedown where the
lines between good and bad blur to such
an extent it's hard to see actually
who's right and who's wrong
we no longer recognize the monster with
dead eyes beating an already lifeless
Peter to a pulp is this really the kind
hearted gone we all know and love will
he ever be back Hunter hunter hits a
pinnacle of darkness in this devastating
moment that we may never recover from
[Music]
Curtis
[Music]
that brings us to the end of this video
which of these moments are your favorite
from Hunter hunter write to us and let
us know also like and subscribe to
Vinnie tube for more cool anime content
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game X Ross Chronicle the links in the
description we'll see you again soon
with a brand new video
[Music]